[Musique]
bienvenue dans la semaine dans le monde
sur france 24 ont fait le tour d une de
l'actualité internationale avec nos
éditorialistes avec au sommaire ce soir
cent jours de guerre en ukraine les
forces russes contrôlent maintenant va
pour cent du territoire ukrainien selon
kiev dans le donbass serrez vos donetsk
est en train de sombrer le kremlin
estime avoir atteint certains résultats
tandis que volodymyr zellers qui affirme
la victoire sera notre macky sall a dit
à vladimir poutine de prendre conscience
que les pays africains sont victimes de
la guerre le président sénégalais est en
russie pour évoquer les stocks de
céréales et les fertilisants bloqué
alors que des pays d'afrique risquent la
famine
on reviendra aussi sur le fiasco stade
de france le real madrid qui demande
maintenant des réponses sur le
traitement infligé à ses supporters
gérald darmanin a présenté ses excuses
pour l'organisation de la finale mais le
ministre de l'intérieur maintient sa
version
enfin le jubilé le jubilé de platine les
britanniques qui célèbre les 70 ans de
règne de la reine elizabeth pendant
quatre jours la souveraine a été saluée
au balcon de buckingham palace hier mais
elle n'a pas assisté à la messe de la
cathédrale de saint paul à londres
aujourd'hui
on en perdra petits problèmes de santé
pour la reine on en parle avec mes
éditorialistes j'ai plaisir d'avoir à
mes côtés antoine vitkine bonsoir
journaliste et réalisateur du
documentaire la vengeance de poutine et
de nombreux autres documents terme en
tout cas celui ci un lien direct avec
notre sujet du jour bienvenue antoine en
face de vous lors simoes bonsoir lors
directrice éditoriale de cartooning for
peace jean-christophe poker avec nous un
rédacteur en chef et éditorialiste à la
croix la croix hebdo qui lit encore la
bible aujourd'hui grande question c'est
un sondage exclusif sur la présence de
la bible aujourd'hui comme
élément de de réflexion sont les lois là
l'iran quand le patrimoine mais encore
moitié des personnes qui la lisent de
temps en temps bonne moitié dans le
monde quand même aussi pas mal de monde
là on dit que c'est le livre le plus
vendu au monde est-ce que poutine ni la
bible a certainement qu'il a quelques
lectures qui sont choisis par le
patriarche kirill patriarche qui a dit
mam est avec nous directeur du mensuel
afrique magazine la bienvenue aussi yade
la guerre en ukraine on va démarrer avec
cette guerre en ukraine c'est ce 100e
jour aujourd'hui les russes contrôlent
20% du territoire ukrainien
on écoute volodymyr zenasci
le chef de la faction est ici le chef de
l'administration présidentielle est ici
le premier ministre ukrainien chaque
galette ici au polo diack est ici le
président est ici notre équipe est
beaucoup plus grande les forces armées
de l'ukraine sous this in côte
est le plus important le peuple les
représentants de l'état sont ici pour
défendre l'ukraine depuis déjà et mon
sens jours la victoire sera notre
gloire à lui créé par au calme
antoine avait utilisé il a l'air fatigué
mais en fait ils sont encore au fond ils
savent tout de même que le dombass est
en train de tomber aux mains des russes
oui oui il a l'air fatigué et ses
premières remarques qu'on peut faire ça
fait 100 jours il a pris il a pris dix
ans ou plusieurs années en tout cas il
est marqué je crois que c'est à l'image
de la situation la guerre est encore
allé non seulement extrêmement un brutal
très violentes mais elle est également
très indécise et donc tout pour les
ukrainiens tout reste à faire je pense
que
les deux camps chacun des deux camps
pense qu'il peut gagner cette guerre et
c'est bien le problème c'est ce qui
pousse notamment les russes puisque les
ukrainiens évidemment se défendre mais
c'est ce qui pousse le russe à aller
plus loin et donc on sent que ça va ça
va ça va durer longtemps et les deux
camps pensent qu'ils peuvent gagner mais
aucun des deux camps n'a pour l'instant
gagné les les ukrainiens et vince qui le
rappeler on voit leurs territoires
occupés à peu près pour 25% de celui ci
c'est comme être considérable c'est à
dire c'est tout bon basse conso modo
celle de mba cesma et même un peu plus
il partit du dombass absolument ouais
donc c'est beaucoup et les russes
avancent grignote petit à petit mais ils
savent qu'ils ont peut-être c'est ce
qu'ils espèrent le temps pour eux est en
tout cas l armement un armement qui pour
le moment est supérieur il faut quand
même le dire à celui des ukrainiens même
si les les renforts d'armement
occidentaux arrive justement ils
attendent les renforts des armements
occidentaux ziad parce qu'on voit que le
dombass est pris en tenaille par les
russes mais c'est vrai que l'ase et
l'ins qui attend le renfort de ses armes
toujours cette résistance sans être un
spécialiste des armes la question c'est
quelles armes de quelle portée de quelle
capacité à nuire
sur le théâtre d'opérations ou au delà
du théâtre d'opérations donc c'est tout
le débat est là et on sent bien que sur
chaque livraison il ya une discussion
est ce que c'est des armes offensives et
ce que les armes défensives est-ce que
où est ce qu'on va trop loin donc il ya
toujours ce débat sur la sur la capacité
de ce qu'on donne a lieu ce qu'on donne
je pense d'ailleurs je pense pas qu'ils
achètent ce qu'on donne à l'ukraine et
la deuxième bataille celle qui se joue
dans le donbass celle qui est est celle
qui se joue à l'échelle maintenant on le
voit on en parlera thaler qui se joue à
l'échelle de la planète sur les
sanctions sur le blé sur les céréales
sur tout ce qui se passe autour de ce
conflit et qui prend une proportion
littéralement planétaire doc c2c espèces
de 2 de flux en même temps et je pense
que les russes comme vous le disiez joue
beaucoup sur le fait que eux ils pensent
avoir le temps pour eux le temps de
résister le temps que laure maîtrisent
totalement leur opinion publique
maîtrise totalement il n'y a pas de là
pas de rébellion interne ça peut durer
des mois des mois des mois des mois et
il garde d'usure dit justement
reste du monde se préparer à une guerre
d'usure sur le long terme les oreilles
mais devront en premier que d'autres
vont demander est-ce que ça s'arrête et
que ben wallace et c'est là que ça se
joue aussi jean-christophe ces deux gars
n'aura pas de vainqueur nous avons
besoin de la paix ça c'est ce que dit
l'envoyé le coordinateur de l'onu de
coordinateur de l'ukraine je pense que
on s'achemine vraisemblablement au delà
des 100 jours si on se projette à 200
jours ou à 300 jours il est possible que
peut-être cessez-le-feu d'ici là mais en
tout cas ce sera une situation qui sera
extrêmement figé avec une crème qui est
de toute façon aura très peu de chances
d'avoir récupéré une partie de ces
territoires malgré les discours très
offensif et mobilisateur du président
zelensky laisser son rôle mais
effectivement ça dépend quand même
beaucoup d armement les américains en
même temps et les les européens ou bien
fixer des lignes rouges il s'agit pas
non plus d'aider les ukrainiens à faire
une contre offensive qui les emmènerait
jusqu'à la frontière de la russie c'est
vraiment permettre aux ukrainiens de
contenir l'offensive russe aujourd'hui
et donc voilà on peut être que dans un
mois ou deux mois on sera enfin les deux
parties kiev et moscou seront en train
de discuter d'un cessez le feu parce que
finalement les russie et la russie aura
progressé suffisamment pour pouvoir
afficher clamer victoire et où l'instant
on en est loin en fait oui mais ça peut
venir en même temps assez vite on voit
bien que la russie progresse pas non
plus massivement et l ukraine je pense
après un temps où là elle a peut-être il
ya quelques semaines elle avait un
discours qui était assez offensif et ce
discours c'est un petit peu réduit et je
pense que l'ukraine pour le monde
considère qu'elle a peu de chance quand
même de renvoyer la russie les troupes
russes en russie quant à nous est
d'accord il pourrait y avoir des
négociations qui pourraient se profiler
lorsqu'on entend effectivement
secrétaire général de l'otan parler
d'une guerre d'usure de long terme
je pense que elle se profile peut-être
c'est évidemment imaginable mais je
pense que dans la tête des deux
protagonistes puisque encore une fois
s'il ya une négociation ce sera d'abord
entre l'ukraine et la russie je pense
que dans les têtes des uns et des autres
ce n'est pas à ce stade imaginables chez
les ukrainiens c'est très clair qu'en
vouloir parler leur territoire a été
envahi ils font des sacrifices immenses
leur pays est en ruine pour une partie
de 2,2 pour la partie s notamment
l'économie s'est rétracté de 40% enfin
ils sont dans une logique de guerre
totale et de guerre longue
psychologiquement
étant donné les sacrifices qu'ils ont
faits une négociation sur ces bases là
avec 20% de leur territoire envahi avec
une progression de cet envahissement ils
ont résisté au départ évidemment
on se souvient des cartes de lax des
axes d'invasion du côté de kharkiv est
de kiev mais étant donné la situation
sur le terrain je crois que dans leur
tête c'est inimaginable en tout cas
c'est pas je le croise et toutes les
discussions que j'ai eues avec des des
ukrainiens à ces derniers temps le le
montre très bien les idées ce qui quand
même céline ski qui est quelqu'un
d'assez posé de très rationnel c'est un
diplôme à d'ailleurs il était arrivé au
pouvoir avec cette image là mais quand
même lui voudrait peut-être un jour
éventuellement à aller vers cette
solution là il sait très bien qu'il doit
composer avec un pays qui probablement
ne veut pas en tout cas à ce stade du
côté des russes même chose alors là
c'est la tête de poutine mais il pense
qu'il peut gagner il a joué il a misé
beaucoup ils risquent beaucoup ça lui
coûte beaucoup et donc il veut aller
jusqu'au bout dernière chose pour je
pense à cadre aussi la discussion qu'on
a scellé module spécial de l'onu qui
sont quand même
édifiant parler on a besoin de paix ça
va on a besoin de paix évidemment tout
le monde a besoin de paix les premiers
ce sont les ukrainiens mais il faut
quand même toujours rappeler il aurait
été avisé de le faire que ceux qui sont
agressés ce sont les ukrainiens dans le
territoire est envahi évidemment qu'ils
ont besoin de paix évidemment que le
monde a besoin de paix mais évidemment
pas à n'importe quelle condition et tout
est là et c'est vrai que c'est la petite
musique qu'on entend le monde a besoin
de paix et évidemment ça ça de toute
façon on a besoin de paix de prospérité
et de bonheur et d'amour tous mais c'est
pas comme ça que ça se passe sur le vélo
loisirs 4 joue la musique elle joue en
défaveur des ukrainiens oui absolument
et c'est le calcul russe pour sport moi
je veux bien alors je pense que ce
conflit se joue autant à l'extérieur du
théâtre du conflit que sur le dombass
lui-même
sur la bataille au sens militaire jeu
franchement je pense qu'il ya un double
calcul de chaque côté mais l'aigle cook
les jambes ont payé c'est absolument
incroyable vous prenez un pays juste
comme ça par l'espagne rien à voir avec
cette histoire ils sont déjà à des taux
d'inflation record comme ils n'ont
jamais connu c'est on sait pas comment
cette opinion publique va tenir comment
les opinions publiques européennes
montegnée il ya des oyats des états
européens qui joue visiblement la carte
de l'ambiguïté comme la hongrie donc
tout ça on sait bien comment ça va
marcher et du même même chose en russie
on part du principe que c'est un système
totalement monolithique organisme qui
n'est pas fragile mais les premiers
témoignages qu'on commence à avoir sur
le coup des sanctions sur les ruptures
d'approvisionnement sur les problèmes
qui se posent dans les entreprises un
petit peu partout ça commence à peser
donc ça marche et sanctions parce que il
ya effectivement les européens ont voté
un embargo sur le pétrole russe cette
semaine à l'embargo qui vise à réduire
de 90% leurs importations de pétrole ils
se sont mis d'accord même si la hongrie
bénéficie et la slovaquie d'ailleurs et
la république tchèque bénéficier une
sorte d'exception mais c'est un succès
c'est la fin du rêve merck et liens et
d'autres personnes de le de l'eurasie
c'est la fin de cette théorie selon
laquelle l'europe et la russie pouvait
parfaitement vivre ensemble en se
mettant d'accord sur un certain nombre
de choses de base et en particulier
l'énergie certain respect des droits de
l'homme je vous rappelle qu'il ya eu une
coupe du monde en russie aude les gens
ont oublié là que l'ukraine avec la
crimée avait été envahie ça nous a pas
empêchés d'aller faire une coupe du
monde et de se marrer à moscou et à
saint pétersbourg donc tout ça c'est
mort et donc ça ça va durer un certain
temps c'est dire que même si la paix
revient l'europe ne retournera pas en
tous les cas pas
politiques économiques sont durables sur
l'énergie en particulier on ne
retournera pas s'apprivoise une
s'approvisionner en russie avant qu'un
changement politique aussi peut
intervenir de l'autre côté des gens que
ça juste un mot sur ces sanctions c'est
un succès pour les européens malgré tout
2/6 paquet de sanctions contre la russie
s'est le plus et le plus dur paquet de
sanctions en fait qui a été
décidée depuis le début donc c'est le
sixième mais c'est aussi le plus dur
c'est quand même en gros 150 milliards
de dollars de recettes pour la banque
centrale russe qui vont petit à petit
disparaître donc ça va être un choc
évidemment la russie va essayer de le
vendre ailleurs on peut penser que la
chine va en acheter
l'inde en acheter mais alors ils vont
acheter à la moitié du riou ils vont
être obligés les russes vont être
obligés de brader leur pétrole donc à
terme ya quand même et à moyen terme
effectivement on voit que ça n'empêche
pas forcément ça n'aurait il pas la
guerre à court terme
encore les applications économique en
russie on n'a pas vraiment de chiffres
c'est pas en attendant quelques éléments
on a quelques chiffres on parlera
tractations du pib entre 10 et 15% et
peut-être plus disent que 15% à ce
moment là donc c'est un peu en deçà de
ce que ce qui avait été annoncé par des
économistes je sais pas comment ils font
leurs calculs donc ça a quand même des
effets mais l'économie russe est plus
résiliente que ce qu'on pensait il
l'avait dit même les russes l'avaient
annoncé en expliquant qu'ils étaient
déjà confrontés à des sanctions et donc
effectivement ils sont résilients de ce
que disait économie sait que le plus dur
va produire ces frais cesser ses effets
dans les mois qui viennent et puis par
ailleurs on en voit les effets
évidemment le pays s'appauvrit perd une
partie de ses élites qui partent mais
par ailleurs on a quand même quelques
échos de tension dans les allées du
pouvoir à moscou tout ça n'est pas si
simple il ya des divisions il ya des
camps il ya toujours eu des camps au
kremlin mais là pour le coup les les le
10 ans us et est maximale est-ce que ça
aura un effet je n'ai pas la moindre
idée mais en tout cas il faut quand même
prendre ça en considération lors les
dessinateurs oui je vous montrais quatre
dessins sur sur sur l'actualité
cette semaine un premier dessin du
dessinateur brésilien amorim qui est
paru cette semaine dans le monde au 100e
jour de guerre aujourd'hui on l'a dit on
entre là dans le quatrième mois et puis
on parle de l'enlisement du conflit
poutine est quand même toujours juché
sur son char bien que cabossé et il y
tient l'agenda 1 pour la pour l'instant
un deuxième dessin du dessinateur
ukrainien cazanave ski c'est toujours
intéressant de montrer aussi comment lui
interprète cette voie là cette avancée
progressive et inexorable de ses troupes
russes à l'est avec son style très
caractéristique il ya une forme de
sentiment d'effroi et et d'oppression
qui se dégage de ce dessin kazan ce qui
a un style très très slave qui quittent
voilà qui fait sa caractéristique un
autre dessin aussi très intéressant du
dessinateur singapouriens ugg
le bras de fer qui continuent à armes
inégales tu parlais il ya tout à l'heure
des armes c'est vrai que même si des
états unis et l'occident constitue le
bras armé de l'ukraine on revoit le bras
armé de deux
2 semaines ce qui bat la russie reste
quand même une menace nucléaire n'y a
rien à faire donc rendez-vous
effectivement au prochain au prochain
rendez puis sur l'embargo progressif
européen de
e
du pétrole russe je vous montrais un
dessin du dessinateur algérien dilemme
très bien résumé sanctions contre la
russie l'europe passe à la vitesse
supérieure voilà on a notre vladmir
poutine en pompiste qui voit passer le
fourgon européen à toute vitesse voilà
c'est efficace et cocasses comme souvent
dans les desseins de dilemme et cette
question des sanctions va bien s'en
reparler puisque macky sall qui est en
russie pour évoquer justement les stocks
de céréales et les phares utilisant
bloqué alors qu'une crise alimentaire
vous savez menace justement le continent
africain via le président sénégalais a
dit à vladimir poutine qu'il fallait
qu'il prenne conscience que les pays
africains étaient victimes aussi du
conflit et il voudrait macky sall
finalement que les sanctions contre la
russie n'affecte pas le secteur
alimentaire on va l'écouter ainsi que
vladimir poutine
mais les ceintures aussi combien la
russie ont entraîné pour le de gravité
puisque nous n'avons plus accès aux eaux
céréales venant de russie ont problèmes
particuliers mais surtout au hasard vous
avez à lui les particuliers pendant que
matt agriculture déjà déficitaire sa
sacré vraiment de sérieuses menaces sur
la sécurité alimentaire du contenu
je souhaite vous rappeler que la russie
est toujours au côté de l'afrique il lui
apporte son soutien dans sa lutte contre
le colonialisme
nous sommes dans une nouvelle étape dans
nos relations et nous apportons une
attention particulière au développement
de ses relations
entendons très bien et de discours à la
fois macky sall donc finalement
s'opposer c'est que c'est aux sanctions
occidentales dont on vient de parler en
même temps que la meilleure poutine qui
se veut le protecteur des pays d'afrique
c'est pas ça d'abord il ya ces lycées
non-alignés cpi qui effectivement ne
sont pas tout à fait dans le bloc de
l'est même si effectivement il a fini
par par sony ou de réseaux même rappelé
les sanctions européennes ne vise pas
les engrais ne vise pas les produits
alimentaires russe donc il n'y a aucune
raison de dire essayer c'est quand même
une partie du discours russes de dire
c'est à cause des européens si je ne
peux plus exporter eh bien non les
européens ont pris soin de ne pas mettre
les engrais et les produits alimentaires
le blessé rien sur la liaison qui ont ce
n'est absolument pas lisez donc après
s'il ya un problème c'est soit parce que
effectivement il faut quand même des
transporteurs et que ces transporteurs
ne veulent pas encourir le risque d'être
sanctionné justement par les américains
par les européens parce qu'ils vont
utiliser le dollar ou je ne sais pas
donc c'est des sanctions plus large qui
peuvent gêner les exportateurs et mais
après c'est aussi le blocus infligé par
la russie à l'ukraine qui empêche
l'ukraine de sortir à 20 millions de
tonnes de blé donc là on est vraiment
dans un discours où moscou et et poutine
se pose en grand défenseur de la fri et
disent à la fois des européens mais
c'est faux c'est faux antoine oui c'est
faut absolument c'est tout le cynisme de
valdimir poutine qui en plus a expliqué
à macky sall que si les bateaux ne
pouvait pas sortir c'est parce que les
ukrainiens avaient miné les les eaux au
large des ports d'ukraine qui pour une
partie sont aux mains des russes et pour
une autre partie sont bombardés par les
russes et si effectivement il ya eu des
mines eh bien elles sont d'ailleurs
beaucoup plus le fait des russes que des
ukrainiens mais les ukrainiens se
défendent mais ce sont les premiers à
essayer d'exporter leurs matières
agricoles dont ils ont besoin ils ont
besoin de ces ressources là je leur ai
rappelé au début de l'émission leur pib
s'est rétracté de 40% ce qui est
considérable donc ils ont besoin de ça
ils le veulent et ce qui empêche ses
exportations ce sont les russes et on
voit bien l'utilisation parfaitement
cynique que poutine en fait en faisant
ça effectivement il poursuit sa
stratégie africaine d'ailleurs qui qui
qui on l'a vu au mali par exemple
stratégie de puissance là aussi poutine
se nourrit de symboles d'imagés de
fantasmes il a envahi l'ukraine pour
pour expliquer à son peuple pour montrer
à son peuple que la russie était encore
une immense puissance une grande
puissance et en afrique pour nous est
beaucoup plus spécialiste de ça que moi
mais en afrique pour une grande part
c'est là aussi un miroir aux alouettes
et une exposition de puissance au
service d'une stratégie assez peu assez
peu clair et assez peu cohérente a
minima il s'assure des votes à l'onu
c'est pour l'instant son seul son seul
bénéfice mais pourquoi macky sall ce
qu'il est président de l'union africaine
et qui a une vraie tension c'est à dire
que il ya eu les deux votes des nations
unies où on a vu qu'il y avait il y
avait un flou dans la position des pays
africains parce qu'il ne se considère
d'abord il ne concerne pas il ne se
considère pas comme concernés par un
conflit qui leur est totalement étranger
et deuxièmement décès pas notre guerre
pas notre guerre deuxièmement les
relations avec la russie sont pas aussi
distendu que ça il ya d'abord tout un
historique il faut revenir à la guerre
froide il ya des tas de gens qui ont été
formés par la russie il ya des tas de
gens qui sont allés à l'université
patrice lumumba et des tas de gens qui
se sont battus qui ont fait la guérilla
avec des armes russes ces gens là ils
ont ils ont un tropisme comme quand
vladimir poutine il utilise un mot très
intéressant il de votre lutte contre le
colonialisme et on est encore
aujourd'hui au 21ème siècle dans la
lutte contre le fait qu'ils sont les
colons les colons c'est les européens
ces américains c'est l'occident et que
ça donc ça ça joue et le troisième point
c'est que je suis assez d'accord avec
vous sur le cynisme mais là mais là la
disruption des chaînes logistiques elle
est effrayante ça c'est très très clair
il ya des bateaux qui circulent qui sont
avec du blé mais qu'on peut pas
débarquer il ya la peur de 32 de faire
des transactions en dollars il ya toutes
sortes de choses qui pose des problèmes
sur des pays qui était déjà très fragile
sur le plan alimentaire
le cours du blé n'a pas augmenté que
avec la crise en ukraine le cours du blé
augmente depuis sept à huit ans parce
que la chine en consomme pas ce qu'il ya
moi parce qu'il ya eu des problèmes
climatiques parce que ceci cela donc
tout ça joue en même temps donc macky
sall a essayé était que cette position
un peu non alignés oui et le quatrième
point c'est que franchement on aimerait
entendre parce que les européens disent
non c'est pas les sanctions les
américains disent non ce cas les
sanctions mais on aimerait entendre une
union européenne les américains qui
disent oui on va vous aider puisqu'on
est dans une bataille planétaire ce que
je vous disais au début on est dans une
bataille ps oui on va vous aider c'est
un peu ce que macro ont dit oui et pour
que ça aille un peu pour que soit le
résultat ce qui est d'ailleurs macky
sall n'a pas vraiment une résultat non
plus puisque vladimir poutine lui a pas
dit qu' il allait débloquer encore une
fois tout le monde joue la carte du
cynisme les pauvres et les fragiles et
les tous ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de se défendre vont payer cher nous les
européens on a les moyens de se défendre
les indiens et chinois tout ça ils
peuvent se positionner mais le reste du
monde si ya pas de blé ya pas de l'es16
aussi y coûte 500 dollars la tonne il
coûtera 500 dollars et macky sall ne
faisait pas de la haute politique en
venant voir poutine en vue de vote à
l'onu il venait tout simplement
effectivement essayé de trouver des
solutions concrètes au fond des blocs
pour pouvoir débloquer la situation
parce que les perspectives sont
absolument effrayante à sont elles sont
effrayantes un vrai enjeu pour le nu
c'est à dire provenant le nu est
vraiment marginale dans
la tentative de résolution du conflit
entre l'ukraine et la russie mais là sur
cet enjeu effectivement qu'ils ont dit
scènes de pays il faudrait vraiment que
l'onu arrive à s'emparer de ce sujet il
y aura peut-être un deal avec la turquie
ouais peut-être entre justement plénière
poutine et erdogan
mais si l'inscription mais c'est
disruption elles vont toucher les pays
fragiles mais on voit déjà en europe des
situations sur certains produits c'est
j'ai vu un reportage hier qu'ils étaient
complètement anecdotique quand on voit
la souffrance mais sur la moutarde et du
coup je suis allé vérifier j'ai fait
deux supermarchés moi il n'y a pas de
moutarde et le type me dit je ne sais
pas quand tu auras de la moutarde parce
que la moutarde elle vient en
particulier les graines vienne d'ukraine
ou de russie et que les canadiens ont
été cramé par le changement climatique
dont ils ont plus de grain que nous on a
renoncé à faire dire et tout ça c'est
sûr plein de produits l'huile de
tournesol etc mais enfin on voit bien
tout de même dans cet échange antoine
entre macky sall et vladimir poutine que
vallières poutine ne va pas renoncer à
ce qu'on peut appeler une arme
alimentaire
il essaie d'avoir le maximum de levier
potentiel pour se rendre indispensable
pour peser dans une éventuelle
négociation je pense que lui je vous
deux cartes à la fois il ya la carte
militaire il veut gagner il pense qu'il
peut gagner il a besoin de gagner par
ailleurs dans la mesure où il est
persuadé au delà de l'ukraine de mener
un combat contre l'occident ça c'est ça
son son obsession depuis le départ il
sait très bien que face à l'occident il
ne va pas se battre avec des armes a
priori et que donc la bataille face à
l'occident ce sera une bataille avec des
outils diplomatiques dans le cadre d'un
grand deal qui peut imaginer qu'ils
seraient évidemment à ces conditions et
dans ce cadre de ceux de ceux de cet
accord là de ceux de ce deal européen en
l'île saint-jean cela les les
négociations à la fin de la guerre
froide on se souvient des sommets regan
gorbatchev ccsa dans son univers mental
et dans ce cadre là puis laurad de
levier dans dans ce rapport là avec
l'occident ça en fait partie et vient à
plein de force en faire rapport devrait
bien plus rares il pourra faire faire
peser ces conditions se sont passés pas
loin ce serait évidemment le contrôle
d'une partie de l'ukraine s'est
évidemment d'abord ça mais c'est aussi
mais aussi l'armée et puis il ya
également je pense une raison qui est
qu'il veut aussi prouver à sa population
qu'il n'est pas isolé je crois qu'on
aurait tort de sous-estimer le l'intérêt
qu'ils portent à surnager dans public
absolument ça compte la chorégraphie est
intéressante il n'y a pas la longue
table voilà il ya une poignée de main
tout ce qu'on a dit sur le fait que le
coc vide le rendez méfiant beau
visiblement il ya six personnes dans la
pièce avec les traducteurs ya pas de
méfiance on affiche une proximité une
écoute une séduction
c'est aussi dans les images que c'est
aussi des images qui va décortiquer pour
savoir s'il est malade ou mais il
faudrait savoir si macky sall a été
testé contre le coc vide auparavant mais
macron l'avait plus ou moins dit que le
test à l'aéroport c'est
dit ils avaient dit qu'ils avaient
refusé je crois que l'année n'est pas
qu'il y avait des tests en plus ce qui
était fait à l'aéroport de moscou à leur
arrivée y compris dans le pavillon
officiel fabre il ya eu quand même des
tas de donc macky sall a été testé en
journée aucune idée
par les deux ont parlé de la délégation
française lors des voyages de cette
feuille 17 février où là effectivement
on sait pas il avait été testé ou pas il
avait refusé raison pour laquelle ça
avait été négocié au préalable
évidemment mais raison pour laquelle il
avait eu droit à la grande table les
dessinateurs sur ce point oui alors je
vais vous montrer deux dessins
sur sur cette séquence quand même
intéressante en même temps un premier
dessin du dessinateur glay du burkina
faso pour rfi d'ailleurs qu'on ne
comprennent plus alors c'est un portrait
qui est pas tant parce que même si on
voit le maquis selon un peu en cheveux
vallier et en ayant et en saint michel
il abandonne quand même les enjeux
africains que sont le terrorisme la
corruption la dictature sécheresse
inflation conflits famines et j'en passe
un point de suspension pour aller
affronter le dragon delà de la guerre en
russie et en ukraine et puis on voit que
sur son bouclier évidemment vous a
reconnu le logo justement de l'union
africaine et puis cette autre dessin du
dessinateur victor ndouna du kenya mais
justement on parlait de la chorégraphie
de la scène voilà voilà une belle
interprétation de victorine doulaye il
ya quand même pourtant un enjeu majeur
ont bien le dire c'est le pain
l'alimentation on voit à quel point
poutine gardien du pain le protège et
que les assiettes ma foi de des
représentants de l'union africaine sont
bien vides malgré le couteau qui tienne
on va passer au fiasco fiasco 10 au
stade de france bien sûr avec ce real
madrid qui demandent d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui des réponses sur le
traitement infligé à ses supporters et
qui appelle à déterminer qui sont les
responsables
gérald darmanin vous le savez a présenté
ses excuses pour l'organisation de la
finale mais il a maintenu sa version
selon laquelle les débordements seraient
liées au fait que 35 mille supporters de
plus que la jauge prévu se serait
présenté au stade de france unissons lui
de billets falsifiés ou sans billet on
écoute le ministre l'intérieur
il est évident que cette fête du sport a
été gâchée et que nous regrettons très
sincèrement les débordements parfois
inacceptables qui au lieu donc le gaz
lacrymogène a permis de sauver un
certain nombre de personnes de
l'écrasement il a aussi pesé côté de
grands dégâts notamment sur des enfants
j'ai encore vu comme voulait des images
voudrais m'en excuser très sincèrement
le de cette utilisation disproportionnée
et les sanctions seront prises vous les
communiquerons si vous souhaitez
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois gérald darmanin aux 10 donnez
donc 1 devant les sénateurs ainsi que la
ministre des sports amélie oudéa castéra
ce qu'il était convaincant antoine est
ce qu'on peut dire on a lu que emmanuel
macron était furieux contre lui qui
l'avait recadré on en est à peu près là
c'est pas terminer cette histoire ce
n'est pas terminé mais je trouve que
cette cette affaire est assez assez
triste sur le fond parce que elle
témoigne de la difficulté d'organiser
serait mais sereinement un événement
majeur ben non plus exagérer mais un
grand événement comme la finale d'une
ligue des champions donc un grand
événement en france et on voit c'est ce
qu'on commence à entrapercevoir c'est la
conjonction des échecs qui chaque qui
chacun pris isolément n'aurait
probablement pas mené à ceux à ce ce
fiasco le mot est peut-être un peu fort
mais en tout cas c'est assez trouble à
ces violences est à cette image assez
assez triste encore une fois et donc
donc oui c'est triste est ce que c'est
le symbole d'un déclassement je ne sais
pas par ailleurs j'ai une lecture
également un peu plus politique et
institutionnelle effectivement quand on
fait face à des as des as des as des
faillites comme celle là les démocraties
quand ça quand elle fonctionne bien
savent en tirer les conséquences ça
passe souvent par des commissions
d'enquêté autre chose que le sénat ça
s'est passé au sénat parce que le sénat
et est contrôlée par l'opposition sera
dû se passer dans la première chambre
dans la chambre haute c'est à dire
l'assemblée nationale et avec les moyens
de commission denquête qui ça fait des
années qu'on les réclames qui ne sont
pas encore à la mesure de moyens d'en
quête pour pouvoir a minima établir les
faits pour éviter que cela se reproduise
donc ceux effectivement ce cette
incapacité à ceux à ceux à tirer des
conséquences politiques dans un cadre
institutionnel et là aussi un autre
motif pour moi de
de tristesse ça veut dire qu'on est pas
de même pour les jets au jeu tous les
cas ça va donner des leçons parce que le
côté intéressant de ce fiasco de cet
échec c'est qu'il y avait tellement de
gens avec des tapas y photo tellement de
gens qui ont filmé et photographié
témoigner écris c'est qu'aujourd'hui
même si je suis d'accord avec vous sur
le fonds institutionnels l'enquêté fait
sert qu on a pratiquement le scénario le
de vos confrères du monde ils ont sorti
cet après-midi sur leur site la vidéo
avec l'explication d'autres journaux
l'ont fait et c'est il ya eu un verre et
aprem d'organisation et là c'est là
qu'on peut peut-être parler ou de
déclassement ou d'incompétence ou de nos
préparations ou du fait qu'on avait la
tête ailleurs ou du fait que les anglais
on pense que c'est des dangereux voyous
et ses essais ce problème d'organisation
au départ sur des détails sur deux flück
sur lequel on s'est trompé et on a
laissé les gens rentraient dans une
nasse on s'est retrouvé quarante mille
personnes 58,5 le deuxième point c'est
que clairement darmana 10 des histoires
semble-t-il sur le nombre de gens qui
n'avaient pas de billets et ça on le
voit aussi avec les images parce que
quand tout le monde est rentré on a tout
le monde a filmé autour du stade tout le
monde a filmé sur les chemins qui allait
du stade à la ville il n'y avait pas
quarante mille personnes donc ils sont
pas tous rentrés donc on doit bien ça
c'est l'époque dans laquelle on vit
aussi serre que il ya le témoignage de
ça tout le temps qui fait que sur des
affaires comme ça on peut décrypter
mieux
l'assurera là où je suis d'accord avec
vous c'est l'eau la facture politique
certain moment
on peut pas virer sous ministre en avant
un premier tour d'élection
les izards est un désaveu manuel marquez
s'est pas exprimée la première mini
s'est pas exprimée donc pendant face à
sa porte parole s'est exprimé qu'une
dizaine
d'armes a le soutien des macros
c'est une info vraiment une enquête
indépendante face et c'est ça qui
permettra de vraiment
c'est quand même le comportement outre
les toutes les dysfonctionnements qui
ont été évoqués et puis elle a peut-être
le grand nombre de supporters aussi
enfin voilà le surnombre mais c'est
quand même un dysfonctionnement des
forces de police françaises et donc ça
c'est pas gérald darmanin qui va mener
une enquête faso aux forces de police
dont il est le premier responsable c'est
le premier flic de france donc c'est pas
lui qui va pouvoir vraiment mené
d'enquêté indépendante alors
malheureusement effectivement
l'assemblée nationale elle et pas en
fonction puisqu'on est à l'approché des
élections législatives mais il faudrait
que assez rapidement effectivement une
une enquête indépendante qui puisse
permettre au delà de l'incident de poser
la question aussi de la façon dont les
forces de police en france envisage le
maintien de l'ordre qui ait une vision
quand même assez confrontation elle ou
il faut d'emblée montré que la puissance
et du côté de la police on a vu ça aussi
lors des manifs de gilet jaune bah c'est
déjà on était un peu en questionnement
faso manning et gilet jaune mais face à
des supporters plutôt pacifique on voit
que c'était pas du tout la bonne
attitude a évidemment sécurité très
renforcé ce soir pour le match france
danemark au stade de france puisqu'il ya
2000 policiers il y as dont 650 dédié à
la lutte contre la délinquance aux
abords du stade de france il ya eu un
chapitre aussi qui est très explosif sur
le plan politique c'est qu'est ce qui
s'est passé à la sortie puisque à
l'entrée il a eu le dysfonctionnement
est la sortie a eu des agressions marine
le pen elle a joué qu'un certain nombre
de gens jouer c'est là dessus qu'on a
même entendu des énormités comme la
comme quoi karim benzema par sa simple
présence avait attiré tous les voyous de
trois pages on voit à quel point le
débat est miné et on revient pas à la
réalité qui est ce stade qui est un
objet luxueux cette coupe cette finale
de la ligue des champions qui est un
objet luxueux ces places qui était à 500
euros minéraux et placé en dans la ville
une des villes les plus pauvres de
france est une des villes les plus
confrontation elle de francs dans un des
départements les plus pauvres et ça on
l'a oublié depuis la coupe du monde 98
leblanc on s'aime tous on s'adore mais
la réalité lancé pour le stade est un
entourage difficile et ça pose question
pour les jo la deuxième chose qui pose
question pour les jo c'est l'europe leur
cérémonie d'ouverture qui est un très
beau projet sur la scène sur la scène
mais dont un certain nombre de gens
spécialisés commence à dire va faire
peut-être y réfléchir parce qu'on pourra
pas sécurisé at elle
une telle procession à tahiti où il
allait dire aquatiques les berges les
trucs en plus maintenant on a des drones
ya des tas de choses qui peuvent venir
perturber tout ça donc c'est très
compliqué attendue des défauts mineurs
dans cette formidable proposé
dessinateur mais vous allez être servis
on nous bassine avec le bal des grands
dessinateurs français souci est qu'on
aime beaucoup voilà vous verrez bientôt
dans toutes les boutiques de souvenirs
parisienne
ce magnifique objet maintenant la tour
eiffel sous la cloche c'est c'est has
been vie veulent le cf ne crs parisien
avec boucliers police
la lacrymo souvenirs de paris un autre
dessin du dessinateur français cambon
aussi très sympathique la france prête à
recevoir les jo voilà alors le problème
c'est que je crois que le gaz lacrymo et
puis la flamme olympique ça fait plat
très bon ménage selon mes vieux
souvenirs de physique et puis pour
terminer et qui s'avoue servir de
transition stéphanie un dessin du
dessinateur la serpe cas au stade de
france les anglais traumatisé il ya de
quoi cet affreux ça nous a appelés ça
nous a rappelé les années thatcher
voilà voilà une belle transition qui
vous est offert et oui bien sûr une
transition tout fait lors puisque on va
parler du jubilé de platine les
britanniques qui célèbre ses 70 ans de
règne de la reine elizabeth ii la
souveraine qui a été saluée on a vu ces
images au balcon de buckingham palace
hier mais alors là on la voit
effectivement ça soulage et à peu près
tout le monde puisqu'on sait qu'elle
avait n'était pas présente au discours
du trône la dernière fois on s'inquiète
sur la santé de la reine elle était bel
et bien présenté hier en revanche en
revanche n'a pas assisté à la messe à la
cathédrale de saint paul à londres
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron a d'ailleurs
je vais le rappeler
célébrée aussi ce jubilé donc on parle
des relations entre la france et le
royaume uni puisque il a ravivé le
président de la république française la
flamme à l'arc de triomphe ça c'était
hier il est en compagnie de
l'ambassadrice du royaume uni en france
et il a posté un message on va en
écouter tout de même un extrait parce
qu'on va voir que justement ce message
c'est vraiment la paix c'est l'unité
entre la grande bretagne entre le
royaume uni et la france ont l'écoutent
emmanuel macron
d'urs fischer joris et cindy perfection
france a few
of human life
le protecteur
used by
général de gaulle et new home to its way
to welcome you in iz
sauce aux fruits
[Musique]
le fil d'or entre nos deux pays parce
que cette vidéo emmanuel macron l'a
postée en anglais mais il a aussi posté
en français antoine donc de quoi faire
oublier ce qui s'est passé au stade de
france et tensions oui il ya peut-être
il ya peut-être ça en arrière pensée
c'est c'est possible j'imagine que le
message était prévu depuis peut-être
plus longtemps que ce match je veux
juste la coïncidence est à ses intérêts
la coïncidence est intéressante bon j'ai
alors je dois dire que ironiquement on
pourrait dire que finalement un monarque
parle à une monarque puisque on reproche
on reproche à la présidence française
d'être très monarchique et ça m'amène à
ma réflexion peut être un peu plus de
fond parce que alors saisissant la reine
d'angleterre j'ai pas beaucoup d'avis
sur la question j'ai une certaine
sympathie personnelle pour le personnage
que je connais plus par la série the
queen que par ailleurs mais elle m'a
l'air très sympathique
ça en reste là c'est une héritière elle
a hérité par son père de cette fonction
elle assume très bien n'ont en revanche
que je trouve intéressant au delà de la
boutade sur les deux monarques c'est que
elle incarne peut-être quelque chose
dont la france aurait peut-être besoin
c'est-à-dire du principe d'un tiers qui
n'est pas qui nous gouverne pas et qui
est qui permet finalement à celui qui
exerce le pouvoir alors royaume uni
c'est le premier ministre en france ça
pourrait être un premier ministre
responsable devant lâche devant la
devant la chambre qui pourrait
finalement avoir autant de pouvoir que
aujourd'hui un président de la
république française qu'un emmanuel
macron boris johnson a énormément de
pouvoir il a peut-être un peu moins que
macro mais il en a beaucoup et bien
symboliquement la présence de ce tiers
c'est-à-dire le fait qu' on est on
exerce ce pouvoir mais qu'on n'a pas
qu'on a quelqu'un au dessus de soi je
trouve ça assez intéressant dans les
déséquilibres
politique que nous connaissons et
monarchie constitutionnel enfants avec
des oui mais les candidats mais mais
mais quand je pense pas alors déjà je
pense je pense je n'y sois pas d'accord
sur qui serait le je pense pas un roi
évidemment c'est parce que je suis en
train de dire à nos valeurs je pense à
un président de la république on en a
connu sous la troisième république ou
3ème république lui donc un régime plus
parlement
effectivement et sa romprait avec ses
moments de l'élection présidentielle qui
est une dimension un peu hystérique où
on cherche finalement à chaque fois un
nouveau roi est donc un sauveur et bien
peut-être que ça nous ferait du bien
d'avoir alors non pas un roi ou une
reine j'ai fait psion pas favorable ce
sera un peu compliqué à remettre en
place mais effectivement quelqu'un qui
est un peu cette quinqua l'angle régime
parlementaire
par le moteur en anglais en tout cas les
britanniques ne s'inspirerait pas du
modèle républicain français n'ont saisi
yade a priori mais certain nombre des
républicains en orient min mais je suis
pas très sûr pas trop surpris par la
déclaration d'amour de d'emmanuel macron
je pense qu'il ya vraiment un lien
franco britannique assez puissant qui
est lié par l'histoire puisque on
rappellerait non-francophones d'ailleurs
les premières cités je pense qu'en
france on parie sur l'après boris
maintenant clairement on pense qu'il est
cramé que
regarder les images de boris johnson et
sa compagne justement en entrant dans la
cathédrale aujourd'hui et bien
lorsqu'ils sont rentrés autant vous dire
que boris johnson johnson s'est fait
huer c'est quand même assez assez
particulier et au col britannique
imposerait un certain recul un certain
recul donc manifestement il a été
chapeau
on entend
le premier mise mais tannique
[Musique]
bide comme idée
avec sa campagne alors qu'il entrait
justement pour ces célébrations de ce
jubilé dans la cathédrale de saint paul
à londres une malle un baiser bonne idée
pour dire l affût populaire je suis en
ce moment en tout cas la reine elizabeth
may la reine elizabeth en france c'est
c'est le lien le plus fort qui existe
aujourd'hui entre la france et le
royaume uni c'est à dire se l est et on
sait qu'elle est venue très vite alors
qu'elle était reine en france moi
j'étais à l'ambassade de grande bretagne
mercredi soir au moment des cérémonies
du jubilé est l'ambassadrice
effectivement a dit la reine c'est la
meilleure ambassadrice du royaume uni en
france depuis 70 ans on se souvient
d'ailleurs là il ya une vraie histoire
avec la françois mitterrand à travers
l'arène les défunts on aime parce que
plus de temps où l on va les regarder le
faire vite à super dessin de la
dessinatrice vénézuélienne rahima parce
que c'est ça devient une icône punk
presque là est la reine 70 ans de règne
elle est toujours là elle est très
respecté très très apprécié et voilà
vous vous retrouvez ce dessin
extraordinaire avec l'hymne punk des sex
pistols god save the queen enfin même si
c'est des rolling stones on voit les
religieux même pourraient fêter leur
jubilé
les enfants n'ont pas longtemps
d'ailleurs mais l'esprit punk du roi de
la grande bretagne qu'on qu'on aime
beaucoup la danse dessin un autre dessin
du décès du dessinateur suisse chapatte
aussi très très bien vu une longévité
exceptionnelle
et puis il ya cette dame qui va acheter
son entité qui dit donnez moi la même le
maire quel bois parce que ça pourrait me
permettre d'aller aussi loin vu pour
terminer on parlait de beaux jo
justement un dessin assez savoureux du
dessinateur français millions et des
saab est de soixante dix ans de règne un
regret quand même avoir commencé avec
louis et leurs voiles wiston churchill
respectable n'est ce pas personnage de
l'histoire contemporaine et finir avec
ça beau jeu il a aussi un finalement son
petit côté punk le sait la monarchie
cole serait longue ni winston avait
aussi un sacré coup dans tous les
témoignages ils descendent et bien mais
il savait se tenir descendez plus que
johnson à mon avis mais s'est abstenu
d'ailleurs il a su mer il assume le rôle
du grand merci la jeune reine beaucoup
lors laure simon et merci beaucoup et
jean christophe jean christophe coke a
merci antoine antoine vitkine merci ziad
zyad limam et merci à vous tous de nous
avoir suivis vous pouvez retrouvez
l'émission en podcast reste avec nous on
se retrouve lundi